hallo leute ich bin karin journey und
wir haben heute richtig gute nachrichten
für euch
wir arbeiten schon seit einigen jahren
zusammen anziehen längen der epidemie
entwickelt hat und ab sofort ist sie
lang endlich als mobile app für ios und
android verfügbar
vor etwas mehr als drei jahren haben wir
sie länger als web app entwickelt
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch an
dieses video das wir damals zusammen
gemacht haben
mittlerweile ist sie länger als mobile
app verfügbar
und wir möchten euch jetzt mal zeigen
wie sie heute aussieht
das besondere an zieht links und unsere
interaktiven video flash cards auf sie
länger existiert jedes wort und jeder
satz als eigenes video und nicht nur das
ihr könnt sogar jedes wort anklicken und
weitere informationen erhalten
ihr könnt zum beispiel übersetzungen
nachgucken ihr könnt nachgucken in
welchem fall ein wort steht oder wie es
korrigiert wird
in den letzten drei jahren haben wir für
sie lenkt tatsächlich über 10.000 videos
aufgenommen
unter anderem findet ihr auf sich lenkt
fast 300 kleinen geschichten in denen
ihr die deutsche grammatik schritt für
schritt kennenlernen könnt hier zum
beispiel könnt ihr trennbare werben
kennenlernen
ich lade meine freunde ein
mit unserem vokabeltrainer hier könnt
ihr außerdem die 6.000 wichtigsten
vokabeln lernen die ihr braucht um im
deutschen das b2 level zu erreichen
und jetzt zeigen wir euch mal welche
arten von übungen es aussieht wenn gibt
die erste übung wie ich euch vorstellen
möchte sind unsere aussprache übungen
ihr kennt das sicher wenn man eine
sprache lernt ist man oft nervös und hat
auch manchmal ein bisschen angst vor dem
sprechen gerade dann wenn man noch nicht
so eine gute aussprache hat die länge
ist es unser ziel dass wir euch helfen
oder aussprache auf eine möglichst
stressfreie weise zu verbessern
deshalb könnt ihr bei sipplingen jeden
satz den rat
noch einmal selbst aufnehmen und euch
dann selbst hören
dadurch könnt ihr schritt für schritt
euer hörverständnis und eure aussprache
verbessern
ich spreche deutsch englisch und ein
bisschen spanisch englisch und ein
bisschen spanisch
ich spreche deutsch englisch und ein
bisschen spanisch jedes wort das ihr
nicht versteht könnt ihr anklicken dann
erhaltet ihr eine übersetzung des wortes
und könnt euch auch die aussprache noch
mal genauer an höheren spreche spreche
spreche spreche das ist eigentlich wären
gebohrt das nächste was ich euch
vorstellen möchte sind unsere reviews
immer wenn ihr ein neues wort
aussiedlern kennenlernt dann könnt ihr
euren reviews hinzufügen
die reviews sind so etwas wie ein
digitales vokabelheft das heißt ihr
könnt immer dahin zurückkommen um
gelerntes zu wiederholen
dabei benutzen wir die methode der space
treppe tischen das heißt die app
erinnert euch in regelmäßigen abständen
daran neue vokabeln zu wiederholen bis
sie ihr euch eingeprägt habt wir
empfehlen euch übrigens immer die hälfte
eurer zeit auf ceiling mit den reviews
zu verbringen und die hälfte damit neues
zu lernen
eine weitere besonderheit an sie klang
ist unsere welt setzen
dort findet ihr verschiedene trainer mit
denen ihr euch beim lernen auf
verschiedene themen fokussieren könnt
dem vokabeltrainer könnt ihr zb vokabeln
lernen
dabei könnt ihr mit unserem filter
auswählen ob ihr neue vokabeln lernen
möchten oder vokabeln wiederholen möchte
die ihr schon kennt oder ihr könnt zum
beispiel auch das level der vokabeln
auswählen das geschenk
die geschenke die sonne die sonne
die stelle war umzug monaten vergessen
ja gut
ausländer die ausländer
wir haben noch einige weitere
trainerbänken mit denen ihr euch auf
themen spezialisieren könnte die für
deutschlerner manchmal besonders
schwierig sind
wir haben zum beispiel einen gender
trainer und darin könnt ihr die artikel
der wichtigsten deutschen nomen lernen
und wir haben auch einen plural trainer
mit denen ihr die florale der deutschen
nomen lernen könnt die manchmal auch
schwierig sind
der kurs die kurse als letztes möchte
ich euch noch ein ganz besonderes
feature unserer app ceiling vorstellen
in unserem thriller game tretet ihr
gegen andere deutschland an und testet
euer herr verständnis und euer wissen
so könnt ihr schritt für schritt besser
darin werden auf deutsch zu denken und
zu reagieren
das ist das gegenteil von ausgang
ja eingang ist das gegenteil vom ausgang
wir würden uns wahnsinnig freuen wenn
ihr sie denken jetzt selbst ausprobiert
ladet die app herunter im google
facebook oder im app store und wenn euch
sie ihnen gefällt dann hinterlasst auch
gerne einen kommentar in den reviews
dankeschön und bis bald
[Musik]